so I have definitely bowled a crush on
Instagram that's why one way of hitting
on someone
I watched my friend do it all the times
like follows of dams leave like some
part eyes are kissing like kissing emoji
I think I put sparkles everywhere where
you could blow her feet up with legs it
works
oh yeah you definitely like succeed I
follow that person on off a different
account because I don't want them to
know that it was me requesting them if
you have a crush you I think you should
snapchat them it could be funny and they
get a little more insight into your
personality
think if you stopped out them like
consecutively over many days and you
guys like formulate a side street it's
like a mutual interest goes through
coming back things hard eyes whatever
boom got in the bag